いやー
てって欲しいなぁ今日は弾み社長です
おはようございますそうつを朝8時で
ございます私3軒の家に住み始めて約1年
もう約1年くらい経つんですけれども
やっぱり一人で行って思うことは寂しい
寂しいんですよもういえば広い小部屋は
多い夜一人で寝るとき本当に怖いなって
思ってるよってそんなときうさそんな時に
えっつがいたら怖くないと思いませんかね
私は思いましたはじめ者ゾーンより足り
ないものは何か
ベッドに的で今日ですねちょっととある
ベッドを1回を家に呼んでみてどんな感じ
なのかなっていうのはちょっと体験してみ
たいなと思っておりますあもう今日来て
くれるペットきてるみたいですね朝から
ありがとうのペットです4強飲んでる
大掛かりですねー
トラックで包んだおはようございます
[音楽]
折戸が使う感じなんだね
重いなぁ
[音楽]
[拍手]
can go
コアはい好きで出ると of 解説という
形できました
ぶー
だ場ですかねやばい大きさのおりなんです
けど舌下強くなっていたんですけどもう
ちょっと先するね始め6月場所さあもう
すぐこのおりに新しい仲間がやってくると
いうことで皆多分準備してるのかなもう
すぐ来ると思います
誰かな
関田こいです
おおうううううっ
じゃれん
[音楽]
小さはいそういうわけねー今回私がお家で
カーン
嘘です会話しないですペットで会話しない
んですけども今日一日のうちでにしたに
生活してくれるお友達の月のアトラクん
ですね今日は
ねえぞ
可愛いねと想像してたツキノワグマとと
いうなんかオフ主来てめっちゃ混むん大型
犬みたいな感じで可愛いんですけどもみな
さんアトッチはいけませんツキノワグマ
かなり危険でございます彼がでかい音を家
に寄ったことあるんですけどもみて
くださいこれ黄色い太鼓の中より多くに
言ってはいけないというサインですこれ
ちゃんの撮影にすおい厳しいルールがあっ
て本会ちゃんと行政から許可を得て撮影し
ておりますラインを寄り切ります
ん攻撃力とかわかんないけど結構人間に
近い生き物だから脚光具体的な危険と言わ
れてるらしくて5メートルぐらいのが結構
可愛いらしいですけども実際かなり危険な
のでちゃんと許可を得て撮影しております
これさん所沢ってくま買ってるじゃない
ですかというグミのクマ好きなんですよ
イメージはありますですよねクマ好きなら
ちょっと実別のクマと一緒に打ってみたい
なぁと思って今回ちょっと熊さんに来て
もらいました今日はねー
とって動物でこすって買うの相当難しい
ませんで買いが再燃の儲けは1日釜座と
一緒に合わせて生活したいと思いますあと
どーすかこれじゃあ今日って聞くように
埋まってたこのまーちゃそんなイメージ
ないですけど
デカ目日給されたさん怖いねみなさーん
[音楽]
ガム子だねぺろぺろしているお腹すいてる
な付いてるんだねあげてみましょうか
ずっとは入れないのですギリギリで軍は爪
やばなんか可愛らしいと面白く作ってみ
たら結構怖いわわーんわーん
ごはん用のれないいるじゃあねっ
はいどうぞよくできました
めっちゃサクサクしとるっ
あっはぁまだクレイみたら出されている
食いしん坊なので君わー
技ん
もいい
消えません可愛い大人強い子みたいな智子
これは大人成功ですが使ってい
また触れ感すごい打され2部に分けてみる
えっ
例えば ls ちょっとこんな機会ない
よかっちょっと比例は熊に餌あげることに
ないから熱湯には動物系の向きを通される
ぎーです動物アレルギーでも触れ合わ
なければ大丈夫ナースのかがんばれ
がんばれ
もう
ばいばいこれだっ
よくできましたーーー
かわいい
写っとるがな
このサイズでも怖いからさを切らの夢と
理解すらせからもっとこういう載せる沿い
えええええフォルダが犬みたい
南加瀬2メートル幅いいなと思ってつけて
いると需要創出ね爪とかマゾでごめんな
綺麗な花がいつ並び立つで待つそうなので
最後さっすがに管理人はうちにクマがいる
と思わないでしょ目隠ししてここまで連れ
てきて目の前に車がいてビックリさせよう
と思いますやっていきましょう
ん
[音楽]
接着抜きはそう来ると思った
水を通されゾロ誓ったいこれ朝出てくる
夜中のハイ見てくださいお得多分変化わー
パーシー
ええええええ
ん
[音楽]
voodooたっかっちっ
me
か
ん
[音楽]
それが近年その子財布サイフさ車戦.なに
より
多い呼びです
開けますこれを開けていん
[音楽]
強いけどちょっと盛ってみてくださいただ
傷の4回だった
ender
ender これ論破
ジャベリン
打ってみた
過ぎるん
サーマを聞いてるんじゃないか
今ああああああああああああ
別の店にいただけてくださいうん
むしろお願いてくださいん
ん
の来なよ
どこ前や
おい
[拍手]
ろんだよん
人やなどを捉えられ-1ザ
に彼が減っちゃう
だして